[Music]  my name is judge janine pirro and i've  been with fox news since 2006. 25 years  ago i was invited to one of the first  parties uh that fox news had and i was a  sitting d.a at the time and you know  here was this fledgling news channel  and you know was competing with the big  guys and yet there was something about  it that was different television it's a  very verbal media and we always knew  that it would succeed but it has  succeeded beyond our imagination you  can't force people to watch a news  channel they do it because they feel  that there's something in it for them  coming up on justice all the time as i  crisscross this country people will say  you know as soon as it's nine o'clock no  one can speak in our house i'm floored  when i hear people say that never ever  did i think that people would notice me  i mean i'm just janine